Medical and research ethics have changed a lot since the time of Henrietta
Lacks. In part because of her story and other stories of research misconduct.
>> And there have been events that have
happened all over the world not just in the
United States, that have challenged our laws and our
morals. And the question is what are the new
frontiers of genetic technology today that challenge our
morals and ethics. What are the things, 100 years
from now that we're going to look back on and
be aghast that we ever did or participated in?
>> Well one of the things, that's really
the forefront of people's mind is genetic discrimination.